mon
des paysages bucoliques digne d'une
carte postale dans cette région rurale
du danemark des vestiges d'une tradition
agricole dans la commune d'owendo mais
du passé
elle se tourne vers l'avenir
une transformation est en train d'éclore
chez les horticulteurs
la tomate est la spécialité de ce
producteur mais une nouvelle culture
s'impose
les premiers plants de cannabis ont fait
leur apparition le but approvisionner le
marché thérapeutique qui prend son essor
au danemark mais surtout fournir
l'europe pour y arriver une alliance
stratégique entre ce producteur de
légumes une entreprise canadienne
aurora cannabis avec ses connaissances
sur le cannabis affirme torben rôle le
canada est devenu un véritable chef de
file et aurora n'est pas le seul joueur
en ville
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là une autre
entreprise canadienne est en train de
prendre racine
bonjour c'est un québécois qui nous
accueille
anthony le moins de lacombe supervise la
conversion de ses serres qui servait à
faire pousser des fleurs
il y aussi de la tuyauterie ci qui va
nous permettre de générer de la chaleur
spectrum cannabis la filiale médicinales
du géant canadien canopy gros tu vois
grand en europe
l'entreprise veut capitaliser sur
l'expertisé développée au canada pour
être parmi les premières à se conformer
aux normes mesure européen
ça nous permet d'avoir produit qualité
dès le départ il est important d'essayer
besoin d'être fait thénot pays ne lésine
pas sur les moyens
environ 20 millions d'euros seront
investis dans les infrastructures de
production ici au danemark
une fois les installations complété
elles s'étendront sur vingt-quatre mille
mètres carrés à terme l'entreprise
espère produire jusqu'à 200 kg de
cannabis par semaine tout le monde se
sent comme des pieds nus un peu comme on
se sentait au canada il ya peut-être
quelques années d'enquêté non tout le
monde est très excité de participer à
cet événement après le canada
ces compagnies sont déterminés à
conquérir l'europe et ensuite le monde
l'échauffement est terminé dit le
fondateur de canopy grotte
la partie peut maintenant commencer le
multimillionnaire consacre maintenant 90
% son temps à développer les marchés
internationaux
son entreprise est présente dans 11 pays
sa valeur en bourse mais passe les 10
milliards de dollars le potentiel est
gigantesque
d'ici 3 à 5 ans croit-il au moins la
moitié des pays du g20 choisiront
d'encadrer la vente de cannabis et les
producteurs canadiens seront au premier
rang
au delà du danemark c'est toute l'europe
qui s'ouvre à l'horizon et l'industrie
canadienne compte bien s'imposer dans le
paysage ici louis blouin radio canada
owens